back in the day there used to be limited
number of television channels
that aired a decent number of tv
programs movies
and so on people generally
enjoyed those channels they were pretty
much satisfied with the limited number
of choices available to them
as a result of this there were fewer
complaints
do we experience the same scenario today
as well
no we don't we have a wide range of tv
channels to select from
in addition to this we also have
internet streaming services
that can play any web series or movies
or documentaries
and much more on demand so many
options to choose from and at such times
we often encounter situations where it's
very difficult to find a desired show
in fact it's more likely to be a scene
of confusion
and chances are pretty high that we may
easily get annoyed by too many options
right but why are we discussing this
let's get to know it in this q episode
[Music]
this situation can be better understood
with the phenomenon called
the paradox of choice what do we mean by
it
it's a situation where we are presented
with too many
options for a particular thing that
generally leads to
confusion and stressful decision making
further it makes the individual unhappy
and dissatisfied with their own
decisions
sounds unreal right well let's speculate
and check imagine we want to buy a good
phone
we know that the market is flooded with
n number of phones
choosing one phone out of the many
options available
is really a mammoth task so generally
with the pre-decided budget
we go through tech reviews and check all
the pros and cons
after spending a lot of time and energy
we decide to buy a phone
which we feel is a perfect one for us
but sometimes within a few days a new
phone enters the market
with better specifications and for the
same price
also the price of the phone that we
purchased would have gone down a bit
that's where we may feel regretful
dissatisfied
and of course unhappy with our decision
but do we come across these situations
often
to our surprise we experience these
situations almost
every day in our life such situations
are
explained well by a psychologist barry
schwartz in his book
the paradox of choice why more is less
according to him in context to paradox
of choice
there are basically two types of people
maximizers and satisficers
what do they mean let's understand both
beginning with maximizers maximizers are
the ones
who spend a lot of time and energy into
searching for the best choice
from the available options to make a
decision
after making the decision it generally
puts the person
in self-doubt of whether they really
made the best choice or not
it's observed that they are more likely
to be unhappy and dissatisfied with
their decisions
the example we saw earlier of choosing a
smartphone
from too many options and also feeling
dissatisfied about the same
after the purchase can explain
maximizers
now can you guess whose satisfices are
[Music]
they are the ones who look for the basic
needs in the options available to make a
decision
they hardly spend their time and energy
on researching
and hence once the decision is made they
do not bother much about the outcome
they are considered to be more happy and
satisfied with their decisions
to understand this better let's take the
same example
of buying a smartphone now as opposed to
a maximizer
who wants to weigh all the options and
select the best smartphone
a satisficer would just be concerned
about his needs
for instance he may want to have a phone
with a good camera
so he will just be focused on that and
would settle for a smartphone
with good enough camera he wouldn't
bother too much about
other features whereas a maximizer in
this
would not only look for a good camera
but also a good price
ram operating system display and other
features
just to make sure that it's the best
smartphone he's buying
since satisficers invest very little
time and energy
while going for a product generally
they're more satisfied
and do not regret their decisions all
right
so does that mean a person can only be a
maximizer or a satisficer
not really in general a person can show
a bit of both
now what does that mean in some
situations
we behave like maximizers while another
as satisficers
for example for someone watching a movie
may not be a big deal
he may just watch it without putting
much of a thought but for the same
person
selecting a dish at a restaurant could
be a task
he may be very particular about food and
might invest a lot of time choosing a
dish from a plethora of options
he wouldn't want to make a wrong choice
with the food and would want to have
something exceptional
that means we are literally
unpredictable and cannot be specific
it all depends upon the area of interest
of a person
interesting isn't it in which category
do you fall in
let us know in the comments section
now looking at the wide range of options
available around
us it seems impossible to avoid the
paradox of choice
so why do i say so that's because we're
living in a highly competitive market
for each product you're looking for
there are numerous options available in
the market
competing with each other to grab your
attention and drive you towards them
this makes you fall for the paradox of
choice
in an attempt to select the best when
provided with too many options
we generally end up getting confused and
make decisions that often become the
reason
of our unhappiness and dissatisfaction
so can we say that less options always
lead to happiness
satisfaction and no regret
i think that's a debatable question and
we leave this q box for you to explore
share your thoughts in the comment
section below
to be part of our massive learning
community do subscribe to our channel
happy learning